can electrified brain cells in a cluster
when all the games at dave and buster's
scientists have taught living human
brain cells in a dish how to play the
video game pong and may have taught dead
ones how to write for jimmy fallon
using electric pulses to stimulate the
clumps of cells in a virtual game world
which sounds better than human brains we
experiment on researchers showed that
the cells also learn and improve their
performance in the game faster than a.i
meaning they taught a clump of brain
to beat a computer at pong while the
study of brain cell clusters in dishes
is nothing new researchers say pong
playing mini brains are the first to be
shown performing goal-oriented tasks
which can overwhelm some of the tinier
human brains
so
this is considered a major step towards
the creation of synthetic brains and i
have to say
it can't come soon enough
like scientists making a coronavirus
more infectious to human mice hybrids
why ask what could go wrong i say
all
right emily
people don't understand okay so
if those brain cells are are uh working
uh uh uh on their own they are living in
a universe that they believe is only
their universe right their universe is
pong
so in that world they are literally
living in a simulation which means
aren't we living in a pong world
somebody else is doing exactly the same
thing to us that we are doing to those
brain cells we they just prove the
simulation works by manipulating brain
cells to perform an action which is what
is being done to us right now emily yes
that's like the matrix that's the nature
yes it is we just need key on you
what or keanu no key on you anyway
here's what's so gnarly about the entire
thing whatever everyone here's what's so
gnarly
the the craziest part is that this
brain-like organoid that's what they
called it which is disgusting yes that
that they it that thing it learns yes it
learns and so that means you can put one
in a jurassic park
dinosaur it is literally like tony stark
the guy that he fought the huge guy with
the thing like basically you could put a
human brain into anything terrifying
and that thing will learn
how to take over so to your point yes
this is the most dangerous most gnarly
thing we've ever heard of in our lives
i'm totally for it missed the point she
misses the point i'm gonna repeat it one
more yes you're wrong we're in the
matrix that's your point
douglas it shows that humans can create
universal
simulations that's what it's saying
yes and i want to get out of it now
when you two would just say piano at
each other a lot yeah i thought i need
to leave the gunfire simulation
i did why he must have felt that i feel
it all often
all right there's a there's a group of
scientists that believe that this is why
we don't find aliens right because
they're all in their own little micro
universe is doing that and like we're
now just realizing that's where we are i
feel bad for whoever's grandpa's brain
cells were donated to science to play
paul all of a sudden he's in heaven i'll
send a piece of his ripped away i'm in a
pong universe like that poor guy yeah
whoever it was
i just listen if we're in the matrix i
want to be in the first one i don't want
to be in number four that was a stenka
yeah last word yeah i don't know what
pong is because i'm so young
[Laughter]
sorry it's true
um but i don't want my technology to
have a brain because that's they that's
brains make people judge you yeah i
don't want my phone to have an opinion
interesting on what i do on my phone
well
again you missed the point too it's
amazing all right
people at home understand what i mean
right wink
up next they tell users what they can
and can't say but will that finally
drive people away
[Applause]
[Music]
unlimited cashback match
only from discover
[Music]
your record label is taking off but so
is your sound engineer you need to hire
i need indeed indeed you do
indeed instant match instantly delivers
quality candidates matching your job
description visit indeed.com hire
if you're like i was you're tired of
worn out plastic mats under your office
chair they dent and crack and they're
uncomfortable to roll on i found a
premium alternative a glass chairmat by
vetrazzo i liked it so much i bought the
company i'm george pardo president of
vetraza our glass chairmats are made of
super strong glass and protected with a
nanotech coating so you'll always get a
smooth easy glide and they're beautiful
tired of replacing plastic i promise
this is the last chair mat you'll need
and we give you a lifetime warranty
comfort style durability a vitrazza
glass chair mat will completely
transform your workspace home office or
office office we stock 18 popular sizes
and we ship free to anywhere in the
lower 48 get the look you deserve i
invite you to shop online at
vetrazza.com
use promo code tv and save 10 percent on
any glass chair mat at bitraza.com
as someone with hearing loss i know what
a confusing and frustrating experience
getting hearing aids can be
that's why i found it lively high
quality hearing aids with all of the
features you need and none of the hassle
lively offers bluetooth fda regulated
hearing aids delivered to your door for
thousands less than you'd expect and
remote access to an audiology team seven
days a week better hearing has never
been this easy try lively risk-free for
a hundred days visit listenlively.com
when news breaks shane and green
delivers we've got a live report with
breaking details fox news at night with
shannon dream weeknights on fox news
channel america is watching
why do nearly 1 million businesses
choose stamps.com to mail and ship
no more trips to the post office no more
paying full price for postage and great
rates from usps and ups
mail letters
ship packages
anytime
anywhere
for less
a lot less get our special tv offer a
four week trial plus postage and a
digital scale go to stamps.com try and
never go to the post office again
i got this mountain bike for only eleven
dollars
dealdash.com the fair and honest bidding
site this kitchenaid mixer sold for less
than 26. this ipad sold for less than
43. and this playstation 5 sold for less
than a dollar
i want these bluetooth headphones for
twenty dollars i got these three
suitcases for less than forty dollars
and shipping is always free go to
dealdash.com right now and see how much
you can save
guys your masculinity is too important
to trust to weak outdated formulas testx
180 for force factor is powerful helping
you boost total testosterone build
muscle increase energy and improve
performance rush to walmart for test tax
180 from force factor guys do you want
to be the ultimate man alpha king from
force factor unleashes an epic surge in
total testosterone helping you build
muscle increase strength and leave her
breathless rush to walmart for alpha
king from force factor the number one
fastest growing men's health brand in
america are people getting bitter about
bans on facebook and twitter huh joe
rogan who's he announced on sunday that
he had opened an account on getter a
social media platform committed to free
speech explaining that he was doing so
just in case over at twitter gets even
dumber twitter permanently banned rep
marjorie taylor green over what it
called coveted misinformation last week
the platform banned virologist dr robert
malone just days before he appeared on
rogan's podcast allegedly over his
vaccine hesitancy
meanwhile debunked claims from fauci the
cdc and the administration are still
posted with thousands of retweets
i'm going to stop there because i'm
bored by this topic
um marjorie taylor green uh cat i don't
really know she is is she related to
jonathan taylor thomas
yes oh good
yes okay good good good okay that's
that's my answer all right the streisand
effect uh you're well aware of that uh
stitch man the uh that's when you don't
know about somebody until
something is made out of them and then
everybody knows who they are is that
what it is and it's great and they're
throwing these people off of of twitter
like the the dude they threw off is he
he's spitting facts he's like one of the
inventors of the vaccine and yeah
marjorie taylor green uh the girl from
the sitcom yes she uh
she was spitting facts too from like the
federal website yeah but she did she
didn't couch the facts correctly they
claimed she should have had a she should
have conditioned it a little douglas
what's your take on this kind of weird
trend i don't know i know that i i tried
to join getter today myself but i'm not
very good with technology so i ended up
sending out the code on twitter
everybody did that did you see that they
told me to and then everyone thought i'd
been hacked or that it was my
moment like that moment when the
president said the word coffee yes yes
this was my ffa moment i don't know i
wanted to announce that i'm on getter
already but i'm not because of this this
it was it was a very weird thing the
whole getter thing all these people were
jumping to it it made me feel like it
was more like parlor
[Music]
i stay away from all that stuff but i
think what we should pay attention to
and i'll make this fast please do the
approach by congress you have house
democrats that are saying that they want
to censor more that the answer is
censoring more they say the the free
market regulation failed and then you
have congressmen like dan crenshaw who
have proposed um new legislation that
essentially amends section 230 to open
to to improve access to prohibit
political censorship and so people
should figure out what their reps are
doing and pretty much it's stems versus
gop and one is for free speech one is
for lack of censorship and one is for
that role the hell does this have to do
with jonathan taylor thomas
that's how this story was pitched to me
he vapes now oh he does yeah
i bet if we met we'd probably be good
friends i'm sure you could hang out i'm
sure
yeah you just have to you just have to
make sure you're posting facts the way
the world organization gets them like
how long will lockdown last pick a color
orange okay
what's going on dr fauci says
it'll last as long as it lasts there you
go oh
put that on twitter and it won't get
banned oh god
where am i yeah
we'll be right back
as a dj i know all about customization
that's why i love liberty mutual they
customize my car insurance so only pay
for what i need how about a throwback
such tremendous views i'm out of moss
for words when a cough tries to steal
dad's punch lines he takes robitussin
naturals powered by 100 drug-free
ingredients are you gonna leave me
hanging
soothe your cough naturally hello i'm
mike lindell the ceo of my pillow cancer
culture has not only affected myself and
my pillow but millions of you out there
my employees and i want to personally
thank each and every one of you for all
of your support at my pillow we not only
have pillows but we have hundreds of
products including my new slippers
bathrobe sleepwear and my new beds
we're offering the best gifts ever for
the best prices ever for example we have
this exclusive offer on the standard
size my pillows regularly 69.98 now only
1998 with your